avant vous entendiez cela
les figues deniau bonjour depuis ce
matin voilà ce que vous entendez sur
france bleu orléans il est 16h 12
[Musique]
radio france c'est fini après france
culture france inter france info
voici france bleu bleu est apparue comme
la couleur préférée des français
ce qui est vrai est comme une couleur
qui fédère
[Musique]
à l'antenne pas de bouleversement
l'auditeur va retrouver ses chroniques
et six rendez vous habituel en revanche
france bleu se voudrait encore plus
proche de ceux qui l'écoutent
qu'est ce qui va changer pour eux c'est
qu'on va les faire s'exprimer encore
plus c'est qu'ils vont avoir plus de
radio puisque la radio démarrera à 5
heures c'est amènera à trois heures par
la force du réseau
la création de cette chaîne france bleu
on les entendra non seulement en
touraine mais sur l'ensemble de la
france france bleu veut renforcer son
réseau être plus efficace et puis très
rapidement développé son implantation à
l'horizon 2004 le réseau france bleu ne
sera plus constitué de 39 radio locale
mais de 55 radios locales ou deux points
de radio locale c'est à dire que nous
passerons de 50 % de la couverture
nationale à 85% au couverture nationale
des unions 16 nouvelles implantations
mais apparemment aucune en région centre
reste qu'en interne certains sont
sceptiques le nom ne fait pas vraiment
jeune et puis ils craignent de perdre
leur spécificité le réseau selon eux
risque de gommer les différences entre
les régions alors france bleu sur at-il
un succès réponse dans plusieurs mois
lors des prochains sondages
voilà
[Musique]